[Music]
i finally got to try an ionic 5. so i
was gonna do this whole video on the
state of evs electric cars and i was
doing all this research and looking into
it and the more i thought about it the
more i realized i really only had one
major point to make which is that if the
future of cars is electric then we're
eventually going to have to get some
really good affordable electric cars
like there's a lot of really good
electric cars out there already and
they're really tempting but they're all
so expensive at least more expensive
than their gas counterparts and i also
do remember when i had that conversation
with elon musk in the tesla factory a
while ago and i asked him about like a
potential 25 000
good mass production electric car if
that was even possible and he said yes
and that answer has like made headlines
over and over again every few years
since then but the truth is it's never
been harder to make cars than right now
and it's never been more expensive to
make cars in right now obviously supply
chain issues and it's hard to make a new
electric car for all these companies but
the point is yeah we're eventually going
to have to get some good cheaper
electric cars and this ionic 5 that i've
been driving around for about two weeks
has convinced me that we are right on
the cusp of that so the ionic
to me stay with me is kind of like the
samsung zflip4 like it's one of the
least expensive options in an expensive
new category
plus a flip phone in 2022 kind of has a
little bit of a retro future vibe and so
does this car i have started a new
channel to talk about all my thoughts on
cars i actually have quite a few of them
so the first video is on the rivian r1t
that i just took delivery of and we're
actually already using it to shoot this
video because that's what i got it for
it beat the cyber truck to market by
quite a bit either way you can go
subscribe over there if you're
interested i'm really excited about that
channel i'm probably gonna shoot most of
that stuff on whatever phone i'm testing
at the time but the autofocus videos no
need to fear will still be here on this
main channel and i was so excited to
test out the ionic 5. see at some point
i just started seeing them around more
and more like there's a lot of teslas on
the road already so they kind of blend
in at this point i also feel like i see
a mustang mock e every other day but
these ionics just started popping up and
got my attention and i kept wondering
like okay wow lots of people are buying
them they must be pretty good right
they're picking them over other options
and now after driving the thing for like
two weeks i get it i fully get it i mean
this is a well-rounded all-wheel drive
crossover with plenty of space a
distinct but not super lame or flashy
design an efficient 250 plus miles of
range and a sub 40 000 starting price
tag and it isn't really bad at anything
so on the outside it has this design of
like what people from the 80s thought a
car of the future would look like now
it's obviously a crossover with a lot of
storage which is what people are into
right now but it's very retro future and
angular and i really like it and the
coolest part for sure is the dot pixel
theme all over the car the tail lights
and the blinkers are pixels and the
front of the car that's my favorite part
the glossy black rectangle is maybe not
my favorite but everything else around
it especially the dot pattern led lights
is so sick it's very unique on the road
and looks electric without looking dorky
i mean i can't really ask for much more
than that and then i have these like
four things that i keep in mind whenever
i see a new electric car just as far as
like pillars of reasonable electric cars
which would be solid range
uh fast charging
zippy performance and extra storage so
range is the easy one how far can it go
on a charge right so the ionic 5 was
giving me a really impressively accurate
range estimate as i drove around which i
really like it's more accurate than
tesla's and so on a full 100 charge it
would give me around 250 miles that's
right around my comfortable baseline and
it'll charge up to a ridiculous 350
kilowatts which would theoretically take
it from 10 percent to 80 charge in 20
minutes now most of these chargers
available to this car aren't that fast
but that's another story for another day
but then the zippy performance is the
other easy part this is the dual motor
all-wheel drive variant so it's a little
more powerful than the single motor 300
mile version but with a little less
range and it's easily as quick as any of
its gas powered equivalents i think on
paper it's like a five second zero to
sixty which is already pretty good but
it's not even about that it's the zero
to thirty or the twenty to forty like
just zipping around town or merging onto
highways and with all that it's very
responsive now the last pillar i say is
extra storage because when you get rid
of the gas engine obviously there's just
a bunch of extra space and all the parts
that come with it are gone and so every
company has a different way of taking
advantage of that extra space so rivien
did a pickup truck with a gear tunnel
and lots of other cars like tesla and
ford have added a front trunk the ioniq
does have a front trunk but it's so
small that i don't really count it
really they just extended the wheelbase
and made a crossover suv with a ton of
internal storage big big trunk lots of
legroom and headroom in there and a ton
of space between the seats and there's
even this like movable armrest thing
between the front seats honestly other
than that this is a pretty average if
not slightly subpar interior for a 45
000 car but if nothing else it is
spacious so i say it checks that ev box
so the ionic hits all those fundamentals
which you know if we were missing one of
those then i would sort of question like
maybe i can't recommend this or i'd
question why it's missing it but it has
all that stuff so that means everything
else is just extra you know stuff like
software features
autopilot type stuff
creature comforts little quirks and
features so i'll give you a few things
that the ionic does that i really like
and then some other things that i don't
like so much so the ionic has paddle
shifters which might sound kind of weird
for a one gear electric car but they
adjust between levels of regenerative
braking so you can adjust on the fly
with the paddles between coasting like a
regular gas car all the way to one pedal
driving where it breaks when you come
off the accelerator it's not the first
time i've seen that but i like it a lot
that is dope it also has an hud up front
with this top tier spec it has a really
solid traffic aware cruise control that
takes over on highway driving and makes
stop and go traffic way easier and it
supports both android auto and apple
carplay which is convenient because
aside from these capacitive buttons
which really should have either been
full on touchscreen or regular buttons i
think the worst thing in this car
is the maps and it's funny the software
and navigating around is actually pretty
responsive it's totally fine and the
features are nice it shows you how much
range you'll get in each driving mode
plus how much extra you can get if you
don't use the air conditioner but the
second i pop into the maps which is
theoretically the most important part of
an electric car it's brutally slow and
clunky and unintuitive so apple carplay
and android auto are great you know
in-car replacements for the ui but they
aren't particularly good at charging
stuff so they don't know as of right now
if you're driving an electric car or not
and so if you're planning a trip they
don't know how many miles of battery you
have when you arrive at the charger and
how long you need to stop before you
need to go again it's uh you kind of
need to rely on it so again android auto
apple carplay really good but for
actually doing a road trip and
navigating through chargers and planning
that way you kind of need the in-car map
to be good i might have to add that to
my electric car fundamentals anyway i
tweeted a few weeks ago there was this
sick hyundai like track concept car and
i was like yeah whoever's doing design
for hyundai right now keep it up you are
absolutely killing it and that's i think
the last thing i want to talk about
which i think is kind of underrated in
this whole electric car revolution which
is rolling out your first electric car
for all these companies is basically an
opportunity to rebrand to start over a
little bit and create a fresh reputation
like if you think about it hyundai might
be the best example like what in the
last three three four years what did you
think about hyundai you know the tucson
the santa fe you know in the u.s they're
typically 20 to 30k
pretty reasonable affordable cars but
now all of a sudden this new car is 40
to 50k and is considered one of the more
affordable impressive easy to recommend
options in a new category so i guess
what i'm trying to say is these these
car companies can create a whole new
reputation
from scratch for this new audience
especially of younger people who are
going to grow up and eventually buy
their first car that may just be an
electric car so if your reputation was
already good like a ford then maybe
don't think too hard about it if you're
coming out with an f-150 that's electric
just name it the f-150 lightning but if
you're looking for a change in
reputation that i think that a lot of
companies are then this is an
opportunity for them just saying anyway
i get it now i get the ionic 5 and i'm
glad i got to test it from the eevee
fundamentals to the distinct design
that's not too weird not too quirky but
pretty sweet i think it's great it's not
cheap
but it is one of the most affordable evs
at this moment in time uh so yeah i get
it and not only do i get it but this is
the exact car i think we're gonna need
to see a lot more of to sort of usher in
our electric car
future
anyway go subscribe to the cars channel
if you want i'll see you over there it's
below the like button thanks for
watching this one catch you guys later
peace